[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est vrai une foule et je voyais mon
[ __ ] mais michael keaton déguisée en
catwoman
c'est qu'il je suis sûr qu'il est venu
des états unis
écoute attend c'est quand même une
émission qui marche bien la politique et
bluff pensait titoff bluff titoff bluffe
tout le monde tombe dit it up l'oeuf à
huy ont pensé que je plafond penser qu'à
michael keaton
non je pense qu'il a confondu michael
keaton avec quelqu'un qui lui ressemble
donc si le ps revient de peur ce père
déguisé en batman en boîte manuelle
julien lepers vrai qu'il a que ça à foot
de venir ici déguisé en batman oui je
crois qu'il a que ça à foot et oui oui
oui
ah oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui alors c'est julia c'est julien le pq
sur le peloton est au point de faire un
petit 4 à la suite iwork question johnny
tu vas te promets vie de julie coin
peuvent aller bien là ça m'épate cinq
minutes avant de filer à ta part tous
quand même
[Applaudissements]